Wollte dieser Mann seine Frau
umbringen? Wir wissen es nicht.
Klar ist:
Bernhard W. verbrachte 814 Tage in
Untersuchungs- und Sicherheitshaft,
bevor ihn das Bezirksgericht
erstinstanzlich freisprach.
Der Berufungsprozess soll voraus-
sichtlich nächstes Jahr stattfinden.
Mit uns kehrt er an den Ort zurück,
an dem er Ohnmacht,
Zwang und Unrecht empfunden hat.
Man hat ja mehrere Tausend Seiten
Papier zusammengetragen,
zig Personen befragt,
alles, was ich jemals in den Händen
gehalten habe, ausgewertet,
diese Person untersucht.
Und im Urteil auf 54 Seiten
steht: Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Da finde ich schon, dass man mir
Unrecht getan hat, finde ich schon.
Dass man ermittelt,
das habe ich verstanden.
Dass man dafür 814 Tage braucht,
das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Und dass ich
überhaupt keine Rechte mehr habe
und überhaupt gar nichts mehr,
das verstehe ich bis heute nicht.
Die Staatsanwaltschaft
begründet die Haftdauer damit,
dass Bernhard W. Deutscher
und noch nicht lange
in der Schweiz gewesen sei.
Somit habe Fluchtgefahr bestanden.
Unsere Geschichte
beginnt im Aargauer Fricktal.
Wir treffen Bernhard W.
diesen Sommer -
ein gutes Jahr
nach seiner Haftentlassung.
Hier lebt der diplomierte
Umweltwissenschaftler zurzeit,
auf sich allein gestellt, ohne Job
ohne staatliche Unterstützung.
Bernhard W. versucht,
im Alltag wieder klarzukommen.
Ist das Ihr Gemüsegarten,
aus dem Sie ernten?
Nein, das ist
der Gemüsegarten der Vermieterin
und ich bin ihr dankbar,
dass ich von ihrem Garten
etwas nehmen und
mich damit selbst versorgen kann.
Wieso?
- Weil ich kein Geld habe.
Wie viel Geld
geben Sie für das Essen aus?
Ja, nicht viel,
zwischen 50 und 100 Fr. pro Monat.
Das muss reichen?
- Das muss reichen.
Was war geschehen?
Am Anfang steht ein Vorfall Anfang
2015 im Haus des Ehepaars in Möhlin.
Die Aussagen dazu
von Bernhard W. und seiner Frau
gehen diametral auseinander.
In der Anklageschrift
der Staatsanwaltschaft Rheinfelden
steht später:
"Bernhard W. wird der versuchten
vorsätzlichen Tötung beschuldigt."
In der Nacht vom 28. Januar 2015
soll Bernhard W. versucht haben,
seine Frau mit einem Kissen
im Schlafzimmer zu ersticken.
Anschliessend
habe er mit beiden Händen
in einem 15-minütigen Kampf versucht,
den Mund und die Nase der Frau
zuzuhalten.
Seither ist im Leben von Bernhard W.
nichts mehr, wie es einmal war.
Bernhard W. bestreitet die Tat.
Er sei aufgewacht -
die Frau habe in Panik geschrien.
Mit einem Messer in der Hand
sei sie neben dem Bett gesessen.
Er habe sie festgehalten.
Einen Kampf habe es nie gegeben.
Ein Albtraum für den 56-Jährigen.
Ich habe dieser Frau nichts getan,
zuvor nicht,
zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht
und seit meiner Entlassung
bis jetzt auch nicht.
Ich habe noch niemandem etwas getan,
niemandem.
Aber der schwerwiegende Vorwurf
ist immer schwerwiegender geworden.
Denn als die Kapo klingelte,
sagten sie,
es gehe etwa um einen Fall
von häuslicher Gewalt, hier etwa.
Ich habe das nicht verstanden,
dass sie mich gemeint haben.
Denn ich hatte
kein Messer in der Hand,
und die Frau ging aus dem Haus,
stieg ins Auto
und fuhr zu ihren Freunden.
Ich bin nicht geflüchtet.
Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Und ein Kissen
haben Sie ihr nie auf den Kopf ...
Nein, nein, kein Kissen.
Es gibt auch keine Spuren
von einem Kissen.
Und schon gar nicht mit den Händen,
wie sie sagte,
15 Min. mit den Händen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was diese Hände
in 15 Min. tun können,
aber Spuren müsste es dann geben.
Bezirksgefängnis Kulm:
Zwei lange Jahre und drei Monate
verbringt Bernhard W. in
Untersuchungs- und Sicherheitshaft.
Ohne Rechte
fühlt sich Bernhard W. hier.
Belogen und betrogen vom Rechtstaat.
Auf Anfrage von uns
kehrt er zum ersten Mal
an den Ort seines Grauens zurück.
Erinnerungen werden wach.
* Lautes Ausatmen *
* Schluchzen *
Wie ist es für Sie,
hier drin zu stehen?
Wie am ersten Tag.
Genauso wie dann.
Ich weiss noch genau,
wie das ist, hier drin zu liegen.
Wenn ich oben lag, je nachdem,
ein halbes Jahr war ich oben,
dann sah ich etwas.
Wenn ich unten lag,
sah ich nichts.
Es ist ein zweiter Stuhl hier.
Es sind ja zwei Männer in der Zelle.
Es riecht auch wie damals.
Am Anfang dachte ich:
"Ja, da ging die Klobrille vergessen
oder es kommt noch eine."
Nein, es gibt keine.
Hier haben Sie
Ihr Geschäft verrichtet,
und der Mitinsasse war daneben?
- Ja, so ist es.
Privatsphäre - Fehlanzeige.
Heute noch fällt es
dem gebürtigen Deutschen schwer,
über das Erlebte zu reden.
814 lange Tage in Haft -
für Bernhard W.
wie ein schlechter Traum,
aus dem er nicht mehr aufwachte.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Welche Gedanken
machten Sie sich damals?
"Warum bin ich hier?"
"Was habe ich getan,
dass ich hier reinkam?"
Sie waren sich keiner Schuld bewusst?
- Nein, nein.
Nein.
Wer in U-Haft sitzt,
für den gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.
Trotzdem heisst U-Haft hier,
23 Std. pro Tag
in der Zelle eingesperrt zu sein
und 1 Std. Bewegung
im verglasten, belüfteten Spazierhof.
Man kann nichts tun. Nichts.
Tischtennis spielen vielleicht.
Nur umhergehen,
die Richtung wieder ändern.
Nur hin- und hergehen.
Oder man kann Liegestütze machen.
Hier hat niemand das Gefühl,
dass er irgendwo unschuldig ist.
Das ist der volle Druck.
Hier arbeitet man
nur in eine Richtung:
dem Beschuldigten -
das ist der Name der Person -,
dem Beschuldigten
seine Schuld nachzuweisen
und ihn so
in Gefangenschaft zu halten,
dass er sich von der ersten bis
zur letzten Sekunde schuldig fühlt.
Die Oberstaatsanwaltschaft Aargau
widerspricht diesem Vorwurf:
Die Staatsanwaltschaft
hat den Auftrag,
den relevanten Sachverhalt
zu ermitteln,
dabei die belastenden
und entlastenden Umstände
gleichwertig zu behandeln.
Dies haben wir in dem Sinn
und in dem Fall auch so gemacht.
Ich kann aber nachvollziehen,
dass der Beschuldigte einen anderen
persönlichen Eindruck gehabt hat.
Das Gefängnis Limmattal in Dietikon
bietet 72 U-Haft-Plätze an:
für Erwachsene und Jugendliche.
Gefängnisdirektor Daniel Bosshart
zeigt uns eine seiner Zellen.
Wäre Bernhard W. hier gelandet, hätte
er nicht nur viel mehr Platz gehabt,
sondern auch sonst ein ganz anderes
U-Haft-Regime erlebt.
Wie viele Stunden pro Tag ist
der Insasse ausserhalb der Zelle?
Wenn der Insasse alles ausnützt,
was wir ihm anbieten,
dann hat er die Möglichkeit,
ungefähr 6 Std. pro Tag
ausserhalb der Zelle zu sein.
Was kann er ausserhalb alles tun?
Er kann auf den Spazierhof gehen,
arbeiten gehen,
wir bieten zweimal täglich
Gruppenvollzug an
ausserhalb der Zelle.
Er kann in dieser Zeit auch duschen
gehen. Das sind dann rund 6 Std.
Es ist den Kantonen überlassen,
wie sie ihre U-Haft gestalten.
So ist es möglich, dass die Situation
im Kanton Zürich ganz anders ist
als im Nachbarkanton Aargau -
bis hin zum Spazierhof.
Staatsanwälte hätten gerne
möglichst widrige Haftbedingungen,
sagen Strafverteidiger,
um Geständnisse zu erzwingen.
Auch Daniel Kloiber, leitender
Staatsanwalt im Kanton Zürich,
hört immer wieder, in der U-Haft
werde mit Druck gearbeitet.
Was sagen Sie zum Vorwurf,
U-Haft könnte auch
als Beugehaft missbraucht werden?
Also diesen Vorwurf des Missbrauchs
weise ich in aller Schärfe zurück.
Es kann sein, dass ein Mensch,
der in Untersuchungshaft ist,
dies allenfalls so empfindet. Es
wird von uns aber nicht angewendet.
Bernhard W. auf dem Weg
zum Bezirksgericht Rheinfelden,
wo der Prozess gegen ihn
stattgefunden hat.
Im April 2017 ist er hier
als Beschuldigter
in Handschellen
den Strafrichtern vorgeladen worden.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Bernhard W. erinnert sich
an die drei intensiven
Verhandlungstage in diesem Saal.
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
- Es ist wieder sehr präsent.
Hier bin ich gesessen,
die drei Tage
beim Strafgerichtsprozess.
Hier war eine Wand dazwischen.
Ich bin hier gesessen,
habe hier rausgeschaut,
habe die Ziegen angeschaut.
Ich war sehr angespannt.
Fünf Richterinnen und Richter
und die Gerichtsschreiberin,
sechs Personen vor mir, dahinter ...
... 1,5 oder 2 m Ordner.
Und äh ...
Polizisten hinter mir
und dort hinten ganz viele Leute,
meine Freunde auch,
mein Sohn,
und eine Schulklasse,
also viele Zuschauer.
Öffentlich ... und ich hier.
Grausam.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Und dann habe ich gehört,
was die Staatsanwaltschaft fordert:
acht Jahre
für versuchte vorsätzliche Tötung.
Und die Nebenklage:
Die Frau hat durch ihren Anwalt
14 Jahre für Mord gefordert.
Das hat mich sehr erschüttert,
das hat mir eigentlich ...
Da habe ich dann
nicht mehr viel gewusst.
Das habe ich ...
Das hat mich richtig umgehauen.
14 Jahre für Mord - das war ...
Das konnte ich nicht verkraften.
Das Bezirksgericht
kommt erstinstanzlich zum Schluss:
Aufgrund widersprüchlicher
und unglaubwürdiger Aussagen
sowohl auf Seiten von Bernhard W.
als auch seiner Frau,
kann vorliegend nicht
auf einen eindeutigen Sachverhalt
abgestellt werden.
Gesamthaft würden erhebliche
und nicht zu unterdrückende Zweifel
daran vorliegen, dass Bernhard W.
seine Frau töten wollte.
In seinem Urteil
erkennt das Gericht deshalb:
Bernhard W. wird vom Vorwurf
der versuchten vorsätzlichen Tötung
freigesprochen.
Die Sicherheits- bzw.
Untersuchungshaft ist im Nachhinein
als ungerechtfertigte Zwangsmassnahme
zu werten.
Bernhard W. wird deshalb vom Gericht
eine Genugtuung von 120'000 Fr.
für die 814 Hafttage zugesprochen.
Dann habe ich gehört,
dass ich freigesprochen wurde.
Ich konnte dies ...
... nicht glauben. Und dann ...
... ist die Frau ...
... vor allem geschützt,
vor Zuschauern, vor allem
rausgegangen.
Sie durfte mit ihrem Anwalt
als Erstes raus, denke ich.
Dann gingen
alle anderen Menschen raus.
Die einzige Person,
die noch hier sass, war ich.
Dann kriegte ich
Handschellen angezogen
und ging genauso
wieder aus dem Gebäude heraus,
wie ich hereingekommen war,
in Handschellen.
Ich kam genau
wieder in den Gefängniswagen
und wurde wieder
ins Zentralgefängnis gefahren.
Ich bekam einen Putzwagen,
durfte meine Zelle reinigen,
meine Sachen abgeben
und wurde
in die sog. Freiheit entlassen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Freunde holen ihn ab - danach ist
Bernhard W. auf sich allein gestellt.
18 Monate später lebt er hier
in einer möblierten Ferienwohnung.
Der Zutritt
zu seinem Einfamilienhaus in Möhlin
wird Bernhard W. bis heute verwehrt.
Auch die Genugtuungssumme
von 120'000 Fr. kriegt er nicht,
da Ehefrau und Staatsanwaltschaft den
Fall ans Obergericht weiterziehen.
Nur ein paar wenige Kartonschachteln
bleiben ihm
von der Zeit vor der Haft.
Ist das alles an persönlichen Dingen,
die Sie noch besitzen
von vor dieser Nacht im Januar 2015?
Ja, im Wesentlichen ist das alles.
Das, was hier steht, und das,
was beim Velo in der Garage steht.
Ja, das ist es.
Stattdessen türmen sich
die Ordner mit Akten und Rechnungen.
Konten, Haus, Firmenkonto:
alles weg, alles nichts mehr.
Möbel, Kleider,
ich habe hier ein paar Kartons.
Das ärgert mich wahnsinnig.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es möglich ist,
dass man jemandem
einfach so alles wegnimmt,
ihm aber dennoch Rechnungen
zuschickt, bis er verzweifelt.
Interessant!
Der Zürcher Staatsanwalt Kloiber
sagt,
ihm und seinen Kollegen sei klar,
dass es um Existenzen gehe.
Uns ist bewusst: Wir können
damit Leben kaputt machen.
Es ist nicht lustig,
wenn man am Morgen um 7 Uhr
plötzlich die Polizei im Haus hat,
wenn man nachher
24 Std. in einer Zelle sitzt.
Man ist nachher auch stigmatisiert,
verliert allenfalls auch den Job,
Freunde wenden sich von einem ab.
Bis wir jemandem so etwas antun,
braucht es also sehr viel.
Im Gesetz aber,
das muss ich sagen ...
Die Strafprozessordnung
sieht die Untersuchungshaft
als härtestes Zwangsmittel vor.
Und manchmal
müssen wir sie anwenden.
Auch das Zürcher Amt
für Justizvollzug
ist sich der Problematik bewusst.
Roland Zurkirchen, Direktor
der Zürcher U-Haft-Gefängnisse,
ortet Verbesserungspotenzial.
Das fange damit an,
dass alle Beteiligten
die Unschuldsvermutung
ernst nehmen müssten.
Gibt es einen Widerspruch zwischen
"Es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung"
und wie die U-Haft ausgestaltet ist?
Ja, den gibt es, weil man sagt,
die U-Haft sei die strengste,
rigideste Haftform.
Ob man diesen Widerspruch
überhaupt beseitigen kann,
das ist eine
von diesen Fragestellungen,
die sich in Zukunft weisen werden.
Es ist natürlich zumindest stossend,
wenn Leute in U-Haft sitzen,
die Existenz vernichtet,
traumatisiert,
und am Schluss stellt sich heraus:
Sie sind unschuldig.
Für mich ist das sehr stossend.
Und in dem Sinn muss ich sagen,
das entspricht auch nicht
meinem Rechtsempfinden.
In meinem Rechtsgedanken ist es so,
dass jemand erst dann,
wenn er eine Straftat begangen hat,
die Strafe auf sich nehmen soll,
wenn ein Richter sagt,
er sei schuldig.
Darum hat Zurkirchen im Kanton Zürich
einen Prozess angestossen,
der Signalwirkung
für die ganze Schweiz haben soll:
Die U-Haft
wird grundsätzlich überdacht.
Ziel:
weniger sog. Haftschäden verursachen.
(Mann) Gefängnis Limmattal, Grüezi!
- Hier Roli, öffnest du mir bitte?
Ja, ich öffne.
Der Direktor des Gefängnisses
Limmattal hat den Auftrag erhalten,
konkrete Massnahmen zu formulieren
und diese in seinem Haus umzusetzen.
Welches wären die ersten Schritte,
die du jetzt machen würdest?
Was müssen wir
als Nächstes in die Wege leiten?
Angefangen haben wir schon mit
dem täglichen kurzen Gruppenvollzug
und dem Duschen.
- Ja.
Von zweimal wöchentlich
auf fünfmal wöchentlich.
Jetzt ginge es darum,
über die Ressourcen zu sprechen,
damit wir das
weiter ausbauen können.
Auch am Wochenende mehr anbieten
und in den Abendstunden
für die Insassen den Tag verlängern.
Bernhard W. kämpft
mit den Folgen der langen Haft,
leidet an einer Depression
und ist schwer traumatisiert.
Und trotzdem bemüht er sich
in seinem improvisierten Büro
um einen Job.
Doch es folgen nur Absagen.
Ich habe keine,
aber auch gar keine Einkünfte,
Einnahmen.
Ich habe nichts.
Es gibt keine Geldquelle.
Nichts.
Inzwischen hat ein Gericht die Frau
zu einer Unterhaltszahlung
verpflichtet.
Doch mit Anwaltskosten
und Rückzahlung der Darlehen
bleibt davon nichts mehr übrig.
Bernhard W. kämpft weiter einsam
für seine Unschuld - und sein Recht.
Ich muss versuchen,
das für mich zu lösen,
meine innere Balance
nicht zu verlieren,
meine Zuversicht zu behalten.
Ich habe fast nichts mehr von
meinem sozialen Umfeld von früher.
Ganz wenige Freunde, einen Sohn.
Und ich muss
für mich damit klarkommen,
ohne zu verzweifeln,
und das mache ich auch nicht.
Nächstes Jahr soll der Berufungsprozess stattfinden.
Ist Bernhard W. Täter oder Opfer?
Wir wissen es nicht.
Es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung.